bonjour excellence vous êtes bien
matinal ce matin vous vous êtes levés
avec le soleil de la gare d'austerlitz
vous serez monsieur le comte de ces d'un
ski directeur de la police ne se sentait
pas se passer ce matin quelque chose de
neuf dans ce vieux château de crash
versement à l'impératrice elle vieillit
et france
il grandit et alors et via la piraterie
a fait venir ce matin
le bo france car elle vient de
s'apercevoir qu'il est gros grand aux
abeilles taisez vous voilà france le
consort entre
messier patouiller ce matin les
nouvelles sont bonnes
quel temps fait-il est ce que maman est
là sa majesté l'impératrice attend votre
excellence le colonel de la gare de
nobles dans le salon intime victoire de
promo de boer triomphe des batailles
dantesques à dans le boudoir aller la
chercher maman serait écoutée à la peau
maman à bonjour non c'est toi droit mon
petit front froid on me demande si je
fais venir ce matin ce n'est pas pour
trier des lentilles de - turenne ira moi
oui tu es fils unique je n'ai pas le
choix je vois un petit moment de magie
sur des stands ici les bons belge et eti
demain d'ailleurs j'ai déjà pris ma
place pour la foire de lyon
alors mon petit trop haut il te reste
douze heures pour intérêt ta vie de
petit colonel
tiens voilà ma pistoles
désolé c'est tout ce que j'ai sur moi
pour ça qu'il ya c'est le geste qui
compte alors à nu soit bien et ramène le
journal donne un tueur n y aura même un
regret ce soir j'ai rien dit je suis
avec votre père s'était 35 où c'est
possible
à nous et nous bien avec les anars oui
pour moi je vous dis ça un mirage je
rêverais ordonnant vite un cheval un
cheval je les aubois n'ont pas su un
blanc on va savoir
tiens les cloches chien m'a manqué ce
qu'elle vous fait comme publicité non
dits blancs preuve on sa furia des
années je regagnerai j'aimerais y sommes
papa ne pas si seul dans la forêt une
évidence et des mois décembre de cheval
et boulot mademoiselle vous n'avez pas
peur de vous promener tout seul dans la
forêt et ben moi si y'a bord qui comment
vous appelez-vous que font vos parents
et quel âge avez vous laissez-moi lui
dit jolie tej je ne suis qu'un petit col
alors il est tout seul et je m'appelle
oui oui ou non la petite mercy 1 2 par
mademoiselle anna il sent que dans ce
nord deux des bus au 15 5 heures passées
mes mots je voudrais vous faire une bise
iata catalan la ville à bord laissez moi
à mon dieu mon dieu mon nom a lieu à
trop tard elle veut partir de paris les
parties
mince 6 heures hier sous et moi j'oublie
la surprise party tient la nuit descend
belle à la cour lumière l'impératrice
ottavi le trail course heures 30
non en arrivant sans mon petit enfant je
suis heureux de te présenter ma nouvelle
maîtrise aussi et pourquoi vous lancer
avec moi il veut danser avec vous mes
articles à lucile au manuel valls
vilaine mental
tu es fort
le bon sens
je n'aime pas les courses à
allez vous au plus à quelques pas du
goût des masques et vous tu veux savoir
oui
suzanne baccarelli matricule 2067 la
fédération radicale des balles fin
j'étais envoyé ici par blandine jean
coutu et l'empereur elle me voit la
prise entre la poire et le fromage
puisque je t'aime france ne règne quoi
le saignement tu veux rien à part aux
jeux visuellement même maman ou quitter
maman maman c'est une bise jeu plus
rennais on se fit régner mou turenne
your house est un flop sur elle et pas
longtemps à niort le pp le tpiy le pkra
tu veut régner je t'aime france mais je
dois te tuer mais c'est maintenant tu me
manques et tous ses accessoires 22 des
gardes mais parvient à les toucher pas
un mercenaire
cette femme est à moi allez vous ont
replié vous console mon fidèle flanc
d'un dépassement attaque araminte
rêverait pas trop avec tafer a lu chan
c'est risqué magna
les moines maladroit ce matin il reste
plus qu'une balle dans ce bon balle tous
ses accessoires en jetait france et je
suis si heureuse de mourir à tes côtés
marié au ciel tous les deux oui la
petite est empereur contre matt est de
mise
allez vas-y paulo ouais ok scénario